one great thing I heard you say was
wherever we go we take ourselves with us
that's true wherever you go there you
are it's a line I remember from buckaroo
banzai but I've always loved that line
because that's true yeah that is true
and and for better or worse sometimes
you can't get away from yourself you
can't not to hopefully you want to be
around yourself yes that's the key if
you like yourself then no matter where
you go it's okay right and I know LBJ
struggled with with various sort of
self-esteem issues which was interesting
to see one statement he said that was so
fascinating was there show ponies and
there's field horses and they're there
they're there there are show horses and
work horses horses he says he thought of
it he thought of himself as a workhorse
and the reason he was is because he knew
that he was not a show horse he was not
somebody that you would immediately take
- he wasn't overtly handsome worried
that sex appeal or whatever that the
Kennedys had right but so if he was
gonna be liked and in the case of
Johnson he was so insecure he
desperately wanted to be loved the way
to make that happen was to work so hard
to deliver results for people that they
would love him for that right and you
did an excellent job showing these
various scenes where it was unspoken but
you could see what was going on whether
it was the crowd scene when you're
directing a scene how are you thinking
of a character arc and each each take
well the the way I look at any film that
I do is there's a spine that goes
through a film and you decide ahead of
time what is the story you want to take
who and in the case of LBJ its LBJ so
this is the story of who is this guy so
every scene has to attach to the spine
in some way in other words each scene
you'll learn a little bit more about who
this guy is so by the end of the journey
you say okay I got a full picture of who
he is you didn't play a role in this
film you know I didn't because first of
all I don't really like acting and
directing I find it it splits my my
attention my focus I've done it but I
don't love it you know so and there was
no real part for me Who am I gonna play
you know
I can't be Jack Kennedy I can't I'm too
I'm a Jewish guy from the Bronx I can't
be Bobby can and I'm too big so you're
known for a fast-paced directing style
yes would you say it's sped up over the
years as the world sped up or its you've
actually slowed down have you been a
contrarian no I I actually have had to
speed it up because I have less time to
make films every film that I've ever
made would never get made in a studio
they're not the kind of film studios
make so I have to finance them
independently and whenever you find us a
film independently you have a strict
budget you have a short amount of time
to make the film so I you know I love
doing crossword puzzles I love puzzles
and I try to figure out what's the best
way to get this done in the most
economic way possible so having been on
both sides of the camera from being an
actor what were a few things that you
said as a director I swear I'm never
gonna do this whether it's 50 takes of
one scene not showing actors dailies the
main thing I say is I would never ask an
actor to do something I couldn't do and
I'm not the best actor in the world I'm
a decent actor but I'm not the best the
people who I get who I asked to play
these parts they are all better than me
at what they're doing at the part that
they're doing so I know if I can do that
make the transition I asked them to make
or play an emotion in the scene I know
they can do it because I I can do it I
would never ask him to do something I
couldn't do
I think you'd said 10 20 years ago you
couldn't do this film why now
well I mean more than that it was more
than 20 years ago I when I think about
LBJ I was of draft age you know during
the Vietnam War so I didn't like LBJ I
mean I saw him one way as my enemy the
guy who could send me to my death so I
didn't like him and it wasn't until I
matured I spent time in politics I spent
time in government I had a job in
California government for seven years
that I started to really understand and
appreciate
what he was able to accomplish and
that's only at that point that I said
well let me take a look at this guy
because it's almost like if you look at
it's like a tale of two presidencies
he's got the Vietnam War and then he's
got his domestic achievements which
except for FDR is probably the greatest
of all time and had it not been for
Vietnam he probably gone down as one of
the greatest presidents of all time we
have a lot of first-time filmmakers that
watch our videos what would you tell a
first-time filmmaker about getting their
film made well here's the beauty when I
was starting out you know making films
is that the materials that used to make
a film are expensive you know it's a
camera there's you know film stock
there's editing there's light lights all
this stuff now to make a film all you
need is this is an iPhone you know a
smart phone and your computer to edit I
mean you can use available light so
there's no excuse to not just making a
film write the script get your you know
get your friends who you think and act
and actually make a film and it doesn't
cost very much so you know it's it's
that just do it
it's a Nike
[Laughter]
you